this is a production of Cornell
University
point of Tears here because I think I
did my last seminar here after almost 30
years ago um talking about some of the
same data that I'm going to talk about
today
um and also a little known fact from
Marvin that um you didn't know uh
today's my 30th wedding anniversary
uh yeah yeah we celebrated this week
just amazing there's lots of memories
here in Ithaca because we met tonight
here
um so I'm going to take you a little bit
of a journey of uh some of the work that
I've done here and um talk to you about
canberries I'll say although I did a lot
of strawberry work as well
so um so yeah let me go back here too
The Raspberries can't take the heat but
blackberry's hands so there's a story
here and I talk about raspberries can't
take in the heat almost 30 years ago and
I'm going to come back to that a little
bit
um but blackberries can um there's a
whole sort of story behind the story
um probably a better title for this is
building a cane Berry industry in North
Carolina but I really wanted to tie it
back to some of the stuff that we did
here many years ago
um so Marvin got it all right I got my
BS in biology from Ripon College
um from got a master's degree from
Minnesota did cold heaviness and apples
with Dr Emily Hoover who had a PhD here
with Marvin many years ago in Radford
physiology and then what he did say is
that I did a postmasters pre-doc at the
University of Arkansas where as a
technician but I worked in very greeting
there with John Clark and Jim Moore and
that was also you know it's another
degree there because I learned a whole
lot and that certainly helped me with my
my current job in caneberries
um so my activities are wide I am an
extension specialist I've been 30 or 70
extension most of the time that I've
been in North Carolina worked on a lot
of Applied type of research strawberry
production issues methyl bromide
Alternatives that was a big thing when I
first got to North Carolina I got a lot
of Grants and got my tenure base I met
the permate Alternatives worked on row
covers and cover crops and also did some
applied pain Dairy research and when I
first started we called it brambles
um Everybody familiar with that term and
a lot of the girl we're still calling
brambles that we now call them cane
berries which are the blackberries and
The Raspberries
um yeah I'm also a breeder wear many
hats and release a couple of cultivars
mantahala and bond I'll talk about them
a little later also released most
recently two strawberries Rocco and Liz
not going to talk about them at all but
they're nice strawberries check them out
sometime and then also a director of
graduate programs similar to the dgs I
guess here so
um talk about that a little bit as well
so how many of you were born I guess I
can't ask this but um you know you're
probably born in after 1999
no okay so around that time yeah that's
all right yeah besides my kids my kids
are about your age
um so this article came out in 1999 in
Prevention magazine a really big
magazine all the Baby Boomers are
getting old they're trying to or they're
starting to reach higher they're
interested in health benefits and this
article came out it was a seminal
article it was very influential in the
in the very world and in the Aging World
Prevention magazine it says miracle
berry you want to stop aging live longer
and keep your smile make blueberries a
habit so this was uh important uh a
turning point in the very industry
people are interested in various the
late 1990s early 2000s and people are
jumping on the berry bandwagon when I
was here at Cornell people they varies
mostly locally produced strawberries
chipped in from California but there
weren't berries available in the winter
time it wasn't a year-round crop so
things were really starting to change
with this interest in being healthy and
ability to use berries shipping out the
Southern Climate is a Chile and Mexico
Etc oh I bet you didn't turn this thing
on
I did not so hopefully in the out there
in Zoom land you can hear me now
um
so that article came out in 1999. okay
um and just about that same time this
these data are a little bit old but I
just want to show you what's going on
there and this is some data from a Berry
Farm Global Berry Farms the industry
status from 2000 to 2004.
um if you look at those different
categories of berries strawberries
blueberries raspberries and blackberries
strawberries are definitely the big
berry one you know that's noticeable
there but if you look at each of one of
those other categories you'll see that
very sales increases in each one of them
and the total the very category if
you've added them all together between
those four years total Berry sales are
going up 70 percent it's berries are
really kicking in people are becoming
more interested in them and it's a thing
you know berries are definitely a thing
you see them all over the place in the
grocery store and people eating them
becoming more and more popular
um I just did a lot of data here and
this one is a little bit old and I tried
to go over to man library and update
this just now but was not able to access
this data but this is from the
strawberry Commission in California
2017. if you look at that pie chart
right there just want you to focus on
that one if you think of your big pie of
all the the produce or the berries or
the fruits that are available in the
grocery store
um it's 100 berries are 20 of the sales
in grocery stores each year and it's
still that case I was able to find out
that it's still about 20
um um apples which I know are a big year
13 grapes to 11 but varies as a group
strawberries blackberries blueberries
and raspberries are 20 of sales in
grocery stores
um every year
okay so timing was ideal for a new
industry in North Carolina
um and another piece of this puzzle was
the tobacco industry was changing in
North Carolina when I first moved down
there tobacco was King everybody could
reached tobacco people had tobacco um
allotments their Farms lots of small
farmers had these allotments and that's
what their family survived after years
and years so right when I came down to
the tobacco settlement was approved by
the state federal government and they
were paying Growers to to sell their
allotments
um the tobacco is still there by the way
and just bigger Growers but the smaller
Growers were looking to get out of that
tobacco and trying to grow something
else or really an interest in North
Carolina to grow alternative rocks so
perfect timing for a new faculty members
come down and start looking at things
and I love berries and I wanted to see
what they could do with berries
um okay so now I'm going to go back a
little bit to uh this exact slide period
in this same room probably in maybe a
different screen 30 years ago and um
this was sort of one of the biggest
findings of my my PhD research so I
worked with Todd Dawson and Marvin Chris
and Todd had a nice photosynthesis
machine over in the ecology what is that
department or college yeah yeah yeah
okay so it's across the street so I
bought in some raspberry plants and put
them in this this big chamber and cooked
on that photosynthesis machine on those
leaves and started them off at a 15
degree Centigrade you guys all know what
that is I don't have to translate it to
Fahrenheit and then slowly increase the
temperature and over time
um the the photosynthetic efficiency of
those plants or the capacity of those
plants just went down uh this right here
is 68 degrees
probably common here in Ithaca in the
summer
68 degrees in Raleigh North Carolina
never happens in the summer not even at
night you know we don't even get that
cool at night so yeah it was going to be
a real struggle for getting raspberries
to grow in North Carolina
um so this is if you're looking at book
Marvin is page 56 just to make sure and
it's also in I think we published it in
uh the Journal of horticulture science
or whatever too but I I looked it up the
other day it was still there and we just
went over to the library and it's the
thesis isn't there anymore it's in the
end so
long they moved them up
um but yeah so we're 86 degrees is more
like our summer temperatures and you see
that photosynthetic capacity of the
products are not working libraries do
the same thing they're happy they're
available very
um productive
um so you know I knew this going down
into this job and I worked in I was
initially stationed at off-campus
research station in eastern North
Carolina was very hot and see me in the
summer and those other temperatures down
there at the bottom so they're in the
90s and during the summer
um All Summer Long
you've got this new job just collect
some baseline data you know you don't
know a lot don't assume anything just
get some good Baseline data and go in
there and and figure out the crops
before you start doing anything fancy so
we put in some variety trials all across
the state
um both in January blackberry and
raspberry because I thought well you
know this that chart that I did maybe
it's really not the case you know maybe
they do survive so I bought a bunch of
different raspberries and blackberries
and planted them out and I'd also been
at University of Arkansas so I wanted to
try those blackberries there and see how
they did in North Carolina because
nobody was really growing on that side
let's just do that
um so we see those berries on the
Eastern this is where I was located in
Eastern North Carolina
um this is Raleigh where I'm at right
now this is a upper Piedmont research
station where they're growing a lot of
tobacco so they were looking at
Alternatives out there and this is Mills
River or um Hendersonville area where
the research station uh Fletcher used to
be called is located so we put some
trials out there so you know three
different Geographic zones and growing
conditions in those three different
locations so just wanted to see how they
did and I did take a lot of data
on those and that data exists on slides
I converted those slides to a disk and I
don't have a way to read that disc when
I was trying to make this this talk so
you know it's several Generations
removed but believe me you know we did
the trials blackberries did great
raspberries not so much
um and especially the University of
Arkansas libraries did really well so
and then the raspberries did well up in
the mountains too and we'll see some
more pictures of them as we go along
okay so but there was also a grower
Irvin Weinberger uh may not know him but
he was a just a really sweet man he was
the largest Blackberry grower in the
state at that time he was growing the
thorny blackberries from the University
of Arkansas which are really nasty and
when I was there that's mostly what we
were growing although we started to grow
some of the really some of the air they
started releasing some other cornless
ones
um so he was growing up and I stopped by
you know he would call me a lot he's
like so excited that I was there working
on Katy berries working on blackberries
come and see my truck you know my
plantings
um Kyle was the primary cultivar that he
really liked
um it was the thorny as all heck um but
he marketed everything himself he was
the largest Brewer at the time he had
about 28 weeks
um so just it was a that grower that I
worked with a lot and you'll see that he
comes up again so it's really important
as an extension person to make these
connections to the The Growers out there
and he was an important player in that
Gina could this be this guy related to
what Dan Weinberger yeah absolutely his
brother his brother yes yes there's all
they're all over the place and there's
another brother that's also a grower to
him
um yeah so yeah
and urban has a PHD he was a education
education
so Growers but also um you know tied to
Agriculture and the families from that
area there too so just very
knowledgeable guys
poor thinking so I decided to do some
more trials and these are we have 18
research patients across NC State
um I about this same time no but I'm
still living out here in eastern North
Carolina but there was really a lot of
interest so I put a lot more trials
across the state
um in several different iterations of
them we did also tunnels were becoming
popular too so we grew cane berries and
tunnels and we had the same trial in the
tunnel and outside because people didn't
believe that you know what you know
what's the difference so I had mirror
studies where we had all of them inside
and outside all across the states
there's a lot of driving involved
um and this is just something that I
want to point to you this is not the
ideal trial but this is actually looking
at the Harvest of these different
blackberries and these are the different
cultivars here so Arapahoe notches watch
each other these are all the thornless
types now uh Apache
nc430 which is Vaughn my variety and my
mine in Jim Valentines Navajo stormless
types and then Triple Crown I think is a
USDA and then Chester some older stuff
too that people were familiar with both
foreign
types and we grow them in these
different locations this is ax ax nerd
or Oxford Salisbury and then Salisbury
in the tunnel too so you can just see
they're different locations all across
the state
um but I want to show right here is the
Harvest day so they were interested in
when can these different varieties be
grown so and because we had so many
different locations we could span we
could span from early June all the way
through you know the middle of August
there so that was really important for
that potential industry to grow and
especially here at the end we had a lot
of cultivars coming in late and that'll
come in here to play a little bit
later
so when I first got there maybe 100
acres and that was a lot that's just the
number that was told to me
um you know when 1996 to 2000 did all
those cultivar trials talked to the
University of Arkansas I told them hey
blackberries do a really good here just
FYI
um the consumer demand was increasing
did a lot of extension talks and talked
around
um and things started to happen
um Sunny Ridge Farm had heard about the
trials in North Carolina and John Clark
the breeder from University of Arkansas
said hey I think you should go to North
Carolina they might have something for
you there so they at the time were one
of the first large marketers that were
growing blackberries and they were also
growing blueberries
um mostly in Mexico and Georgia South
Georgia but they wanted to extend their
season so they needed some late ripening
blackberries so um they came to North
Carolina they said you know can you help
it went to an extension and said can you
help us so we had set up a series of
meetings with Farm Bureau helped
organize them as well and within several
just a couple of months a lot of Growers
had signed contracts with sunny Ridge
Farms and there was probably within two
years another 400 Acres had gone in
Western North Carolina and Iowa
these girls they don't know how to grow
blackberries they're starting a new
market and it's it's you know a large
commercial market and is it going to
work
Urban Lineberger was a saint in that
respect because he really helped those
Growers held their hands I don't know
why I did as much as I could too but it
was really a nice relationship to work
with that grower and have that industry
grow and he and him being that he was
actually out there too helping those
Growers with the day-to-day maintenance
of things too
um and they started harvesting in 2007.
um so in the background what I was doing
as well we had lots of grower meetings
so that a lot of girls weren't sure how
to do things how to prune things so we
had a lot of those types of workshops
lots of agent trainings as well
um uh on-farm trials we were doing uh
with these Growers we're doing some
on-farm travels both myself and
entomologists and plant Pathologists try
to get into our presence there on on
their Farms we developed several budgets
for how much does it cost to produce
blackberries because these Brewers
actually signed these contracts Without
Really knowing problems which is a
little scary so we put together budgets
pretty quickly with Charles staffley
um and using different troll systems and
everything developed several production
guides this was the second iteration
there's actually a third iteration out
right now it's not we don't have a hard
copy or pretty picture of it yet but
um develop those as well
um diagnostic tools whether it's a
Blackberry diagnostic tool like Marva
has the raspberry and the strawberry
diagnostic tool so we have one too it's
actually linked to the Cornell site as
well so you know I've got some white
druplets on the berries what is it so
Growers can look at that on their
computer and or the phone and try to
figure out what's going on with that
um did a lot of her charity surveys that
the fertility recommendations in North
Carolina were established for
um blackberries that were grown in the
early uh 1900s so they were making
recommendations for some wild
blackberries and so you know we we had
to come up with a new set of
recommendations how but fertility
recommendations have been put out there
so we did a lot of those and first of
all just did surveys
um and then also helped the nursery
industry get going to in the National
clean plant Network Nursery so
lots of Growers are buying new plants
that are interested in getting these
North Carolina or these University of
Arkansas varieties they're buying them
from nurseries from everywhere they're
just getting all these blackberries and
they were growing outside and these
Nursery conditions where these these
Nursery men were unsure what they were
doing they're just propagating and they
had a lot of viruses and so we
determined that oh there's a whole
viruses we did a virus survey we
contacted there was a micro propagation
unit at NC State that was working to a
virologist that was working to clean up
sweet potatoes and I said can you look
at the blackberries and I think there's
a problem there
um and from that there's yes indeed we
had a graduate student survey at lots of
blackberry viruses
um and we determined that it's probably
not a good thing to buy your plants from
a nursery that production produces them
out in the field because those plants
will come into your food into your
production system loaded with viruses
um figured out a way to grow them in
tissue culture the national clean plant
Network we evolved from that and
multiple other things at the same time
so that also occurred at that same time
so
um we that industry would have sunk in
um if we hadn't got a clean plant
nursery going at that Center as well
um so the current status in that
Blackberry interesting there's just so
many stories behind that that you can't
go through with them all but I think
it's about 800 acres we don't officially
collect data on blackberries in North
Carolina for a new enough industry and
they're small enough in general that um
they don't want to share that
information it's really hard to dial in
at least 800 acres I think probably
maybe close to a thousand
um mostly you using the Arkansas
varieties like um wachita Ponca Natchez
and uh some of the newer ones as well
um and then Vaughn a variety that we've
released from the NC State especially in
east or Western North Carolina The
Growers really like it and it does
really well and it tastes better than an
American celebrities and you yields
better too so we're very happy with
Vaughn
um you know a lot of the big major
companies are there as well as nature
ripe driscolls wish Farms
um North Bay so a lot of those if you go
to the grocery store and see those plant
shows with those those company names on
them you'll see those names there as
well
um and what's interesting is this this
industry has developed in the western
part of the state they grow all their
blackberries outside so they have you
know open air they're out in the fields
and they're beautiful because it might
go to my favorite Farms right here this
is south and Roses Farm in
Hendersonville
um all grown outside eastern North
Carolina they're a little bit more
Tech friendly I would say and they grow
everything under tunnels and it rains a
little bit more in eastern North
Carolina so they want to be able to
harvest those berries every single day
they don't out here if it rains you know
they can't go out there they you know
good but they usually let them go for a
day
um but so there's a kind of a difference
a cultural difference in how they grow
things but we had that you know that
that tunnel trial data so we knew how
those things were produced in both night
areas and said yep they do well a little
fun fact about that is that the yields
not that much higher for blackberries
under Tunnels for raspberries it is
um but it's just that protection that
you get from the rain that really
refills that was important to them
okay so this is the status of the
current industry I did a survey a couple
years ago
um I have developed for The Pest
Management strategic plan for the region
and you can see the darker counties this
is a Eastern Growers here that have
oh the tunnels this is this area right
here and this right discount these
County right here the major of the the
Western but they're still fairly big um
growers in the other counties as well
there's 100 countries in the state
um and mostly commercial shipping
industry how you can see that there's
lighter shaded ones there's so local
production there for local markets and
things as well
okay so remember when I talked about
that yield data when we harvested
blackberries in North Carolina and we
had some that were producing really late
in the season in August so this map I'm
going to walk you through a little bit
so this is flex fresh Blackberry
shipments to the U.S market over several
different years 2019 20 20 21 and 22 the
black line here represents the shipping
point price so this is price during
these years
um and these are the different locations
so you can see Oxnard California that
color green is Mexico so a lot of
berries coming out of Mexico especially
in the winter
um uh Georgia is this darker blue right
here and then the gray is North Carolina
so we actually we're on the map here and
you can see starting here in 2019 North
Carolina coming into production here
prices are really good
same thing next in 2020 appointment was
a really good year the pandemic there
was really good for the prices were
really good
um and 2021 prices weren't as good a lot
of other factors going on here but it's
still the prices were increasing when we
are into a big production so that was
really nice they like those really late
season varieties because they can make
that money and and Mexico is out by that
time in Georgia is out too because
that's our main competitors Georgia
right at this time
um this is one of my favorite Growers
here at James Webb wish Farms you know
these are large Growers they have
shipping facilities and distribution
facilities and cooling facilities he
grow is probably the most Vaughn I think
he has close to 50 acres of lawn
um the the currents uh
conservative estimate of the industries
of at least 12 million dollars some
budgets Say closer to 50 million um so
that's cash value to the farmer and
there's added value and I don't know
what the shipping value is but but
that's about what it is the impact it
has in the local counties most of it is
fresh so it's shipped in those
containers and shipped fresh and some
counties you can't even buy a locally
produced libraries because these guys
just want to ship those barriers there
um some is used for local sales so some
of the Growers about 20 of every of
every crop too is just not suitable
because they're very strict regulations
on what is a marketable Blackberry so it
has one of those white droplets used to
be one was okay too was not they're a
little bit more lenient with that right
now
um but about 20 of it is not marketable
so they use other products they make um
juice and wine and
uh serves and things like that
especially in the mountains they work
really well for that
um so this is what you know if you were
this looks like you're in California
where you
were distribution centers big cooling
centers they have uh you know picks the
berries in this field it's really hot in
the summer even in the mountains and
they have cooling cool Watts right here
and they loaded those spots up taken
down to the cooler and
um did those very simple ASAP
and this is a little just a plug for
Vaughn Blackberry released in 2012 it
took a long time for you to catch on
because the University of Arkansas
breeding program is so stinking big and
John Clark has anybody ever seen John
Clark
yes so yeah he sings and he talks and he
tells this great stories and it's just
really hard to compete with that kind of
salesmanship but Vaughn was planted it
hung in there um The Growers started
catching you know and Word of Mouth by
Growers really helped this one catch on
in Western North Carolina it's thornless
it's late season and that's fits in the
late season window really well even
better than any of John stuff because he
was trying to get early season so it was
just the alignment of the stars were
gone
um very high yield it doesn't yield
really high the first year so
everybody's really disappointed about
the second and third year it's very does
very very well
um tolerant to many diseases a lot of
the Arkansas stuff will get orange rust
and and other diseases when Mom just was
paying in there and not get them very
good in post Harvest trials and in fact
Penny Perkins VCS the post-harvest
physiologist that I worked with and she
said and I said you know I'm not going
to release it I can't compete with the
University of Arkansas and she said no
it does have really good post Harvest
you know trades go ahead and release it
okay so I did
um and it does really well in
Northwestern North Carolina and in
Europe it's really catching on for a
long cane production of blackberries
it's really doing well they're very
excited about that Prospect
okay
um some more pictures of bond gotta show
off my kid a little bit here the first
picture of it in flower there that's in
New Jersey it sounds really well here so
you know every single flower there is a
berry so it's it's really loaded up a
pretty picture gone and then gone
in the cooler there I'm ready to ship
do you have some challenges with the
industry
Labor's number one but you know it's by
far it's just hard to get the labor
um one girl last year just had to shut
down his own little big farm because he
just didn't have enough
labor to pick it up this is a very
intense Pirate schedule there it's very
hot and we've actually done nice Harvest
studies to see if that were working it
works but those Growers aren't quite
ready to shift their their whole labor
to that situation but I don't think
that's far away
um
we do have spring industry right here in
the in the spring almost every other
year or so we get damaged from frost to
the buds and we thought the first year
it happened in 2007 we got across on
Easter weekend that was actually a
couple days after that you can see that
receptacle has browned and just like a
strawberry that's not going to produce
any fruit
um but funny thing about blackberries
that I didn't know at the time they have
secondary Buds and those secondary buds
broke up they have maybe 20 to 30
percent less yield but then they're
later so that's even a good thing so
some Growers sometimes like to have that
little bit of injury to their you know
first
um
flowering set of buds because then they
can push their crop a little bit later
if the prices are good but they do lose
a little bit of yield so it's you know
it is what it is and they gotta play
with it lots of pests by the range
rocephalo we have lots of boars we have
cane dieback there's a lot of diseases
that came in there's always something
and you think you get something figured
out we had um one of the cool things
about the the thornless types was they
were resistant to double Blossom which
was a is that limited the production
University of Arkansas the funniest type
for some magical reason they're
resistant to double Blossom so that
opened up a whole new option there so
you know that we were started using all
those and then
um and then we get this cane die back
and then we get Spider Ranger Southwest
so it's always something right now in
the denomia which is a big problem right
now it's up and coming
so you might hear more about that Sarah
Milani a graduate from Cornell here is
working with me
um
last week that she figured out what it
was
um so now I want to transition but I
want to show you this was one of the
earliest pictures I took climbed up in
the middle of the Blackberry canopy and
a v trellis took a picture looking into
the library
um so this is you know you know I built
it was the the stars were aligned for to
help build this industry it wasn't all
me but things you know all happened at
the same time
um the breeding I have developed some
heatonic floor can fruiting raspberries
and I'm going to talk about that a whole
lot but I'm going to talk about the
repercussions on that we do have
primatecase reading cultivars that do
well in the mountains as well
um I'm going to talk about one of them
as well done a lot of cultural studies
row covers and tunnel and pruning and uh
to get the harvest season earlier and
later based on some of Marvin stuff and
some of the Growers are doing that too
cutting down their primocanes to try to
delay their their primocane Blackberry
Harvest
um and long Haynes blackberries we also
do breeding so mostly for fluorocane
fruiting cornless blackberries and we
still have a couple that were trial and
we're in the later stages of development
we want high quality late season and now
that I know that I can compete with the
University of Arkansas
on the docket there and then also called
studies we did a lot with um blackbirds
as well so just a lot of things going on
on a lot of data that I want to show you
these are some reading trials there on
the left these are rubis breeding plants
you can see within those rows a lot of
variation and this is mostly raspberries
you can see some more Vigor and some of
these spots or less bigger so we know
just through this is very I'm a very
traditional greeter just through sheer
force of surviving out in that field you
know these guys are probably not going
to be real adaptive at some of these
right down here in this row R so we do
have a couple selections that um look
pretty good and will hopefully be
releasing these are raspberries up in
the mountains high elevation 30 200 feet
so almost comparable to Cornell and the
the climate there maybe more like
Pennsylvania but raspberries do really
well up in the mountains there and
so there's still a potential for
industry there and we're doing some
trials with
um North Bay to see if we can get some
raspberries because they want raspberry
shipping with their blackberries at the
same time
um out to all these different from
patients
Courtney Weber's
um we'll try on some hip material out
there too
um just to show you a little bit of the
breeding challenge here for raspberries
so 4K fruiting raspberries a mandarin is
a variety that was released a long time
ago
um it's probably the most heat Tower
it's got some Chinese
um background in it can you tell them
but you can see that Berry is really
crumbly not really good so we recommend
that for homeowners only
um Latham is an old old variety I think
it's from the 1800s from Minnesota
um for some reason it does really well
um and fc344 is one of our selections
um nc344 this is one of its parents you
can see it's much better as far as the
fruit quality right there and Glenn pros
and I couldn't find a picture of that
one if I can just see that and we've got
some improvement in the fruit
um
uh quality
um and we know that they do best in the
mountains from our earlier trials so we
have some adaptations of heat but
the quality is still a problem during
the summer heat imagine that you know
soft raspberry pulling in it office
receptacle there it's a soft little
thing you squish it a little bit Yeah
because when you pull
um and it's just in the middle of the
summer it's hard to keep that quality
going and even the size so these are
this is a a selection this is these are
two locations Salisbury in the Sandhills
they're about 90 90 miles apart this is
a much hotter location and consistently
the fruit size is smaller when it's hot
too so it's still a problem during the
Heat
um we can grow them and the plants have
some ketones they I think if I put them
took them over to across the road here
and put them in photosynthesis machine
they would probably be a little more
tolerant than 70 degrees Fahrenheit
um but is there another way
so you know how else could we produce
raspberries because it still is my
favorite small fruit product but I could
share that with this audience here and
I'll work on all those other ones there
it's just that nice flavor very
um so how could we produce fruit at the
same time as strawberries in North
Carolina and Beyond you know so how can
we do this well
um and how can we increase the fruit
offerings in early spring so we have
strawberries we do you know commercial
industry has strawberries and and one of
the Growers approached me and said I
want to produce all four berries at the
same time on my farm so blackberries
raspberries blueberries or blackberries
strawberries libraries blueberries and
raspberries we wanted raspberries were
impossible
um so the grower is Cal Lewis another
big grower in eastern North Carolina
um and he came to me and I said you know
I've tried it before I think we could
try it again I said that would come in
at the same time as the strawberries and
he said let's go for it because he'd
been to he grows for Driscoll's he's
been to California if you've been to
Mexico and you've been to Europe where
they do a lot of this long cane
raspberries he said I think we want to
try it here and I want you to do it on
my farm and I want to work cooperatively
with extension I want it to be an
extension activity and I said that's
great
um so he donated the land we got the
tunnels donated and at the same time I
had a young woman who is an extension
agent down there Lisa raver said I want
to do a master's degree with you and she
lived like about 45 minutes away from
this on Farm trial but I said Lisa I got
a project for you and I'm going to talk
about long cane raspberries you know and
I talked to her a little bit about the
project and she she hung up the phone
and she told me one she hung up the
phone then
as soon as I hung up the phone I Googled
lawn cane raspberry I had no idea what
you were talking about and now she's the
expert at long King raspberry in North
Carolina so we started this project um
during the pandemic we wanted to go Roll
Along Came raspberries we had some you
know information it's been done in
different locations
um
and it's a long chain raspberry it's a
one-year-old cane that's grown in
another location it's ready to fruits
that year
um you grow them in pots and they will
produce a season that first year and
it's an annual product you know grow it
again so that's a lot of money that
grower Cal Lewis has a lot of money he
doesn't want to invest again this
because he wants to burn four berries in
the summer that's the ones they make fun
okay do they come as as bare Roots then
so they have they actually grow them
here's a picture of them they grow them
um in in these pots right here in either
Quebec or in um this is actually in
Western North Carolina there's a nursery
trying to grow them there so they grow
them in those pots they ship them in
these pots they ship them in um they
call them them coffins and they're in
cooler they put them in coolers and they
arrive at the destination location
um and then you plant them or you have a
pull out date you pull them out and put
them in tunnels in January
should I explain that okay to you okay
um yeah so that's that sequence
basically there
and then previously that summer and it's
still challenging because you have to
put to plant them in January or plant
them and pull them out in January
um so you got a January still cold in
North Carolina
you got to close them up you gotta use
um you know the doors on the tunnels you
have to use roll covers on that bottom
picture you can see that we had a double
um cover them because it just got so
cold that sometimes
um and fortunately because this is an
on-farm trial we had a lot of
labor to help out with this we probably
wouldn't have been able to do this at a
research station
and the other challenge we had this
party back because we use pine bark
instead of coconut core because coconut
core is one that they use in in
traditionally in Europe and in
California and Mexico but we wanted a
alternative something that was locally
produced
so a little bit of background on
soilless
um
soilist substrates cane berries are
amongst the most recent types of crops
that use this uh substrates for for
growing up plants
um the nursery industry has for a long
time used different substrates and they
kind of Base it on what is locally
available so we had a professor at NC
State Brian Jackson who knew how to grow
stuff in substrates and wanted to expand
into other crops and he said I think we
have some opportunities in in North
Carolina I think um or some
opportunities with alternate substrates
and this was at the same time about 2020
everybody remember that year
um and we were starting this project and
we couldn't get the coconut core her it
wasn't available there are the um supply
chain was just all locked up so um you
know once again the Stars aligned and we
had okay so let's go see if we can get
some locally produced substrates pine
bark in North Carolina
um I guess I kind of jumped ahead of
myself here see if there's anything else
I'm missing there
um so it's been been known and used on
other crops
um and these are the two options that we
had Pine Barker coconut core Coco core
was industry standard in Europe and
California or Canada Source from Sri
Lanka mostly it has excellent water
holding capacity and people have worked
with this for many years so they know
how to use it
um and if it worked out the the
fertility with it
um and a good supplier is necessary it
costs about eight to ten times as much
as the locally produced
so that's a lot of difference between
those two
um pine bark it was produced locally we
have a lot of Pines North Carolina
there's some um
mulch
Distributors that have worked with us
with the nursery industry in North
Carolina for a long time and really are
able to dial in the size of your
particulate in that when that Pine Bar
been really able to
um deliver you a consistent product so
they figured out how to do that it has a
it's a little bit trickier it's not the
same as a coconut core so we that was
mostly what we were doing is learning
how to grow it in Pine bark we had
different fertility issues
um but he was willing her they were
willing to supply that with us you know
every year so it was really
locally producing so it's Sri Lanka was
an hour and a half drive away from this
this Growers
and this is the season what it would
look like I'm skipping over a lot of
stuff you know so you plant it out pull
it out in January starts to Leaf out to
see a lot of activity and these are just
really consistent plants look at these
um you know there's laterals coming out
very consistently they're a really
beautiful fruit it's humming with bees
and just a really nice
um Fruit Harvest there too and that's
quelly uh raspberry red raspberry that
we found out it wasn't the best flavor
but it was the most consistent quality
in that system for us
um so this is what the system looks like
um you know so very high density in the
in the tunnel I think they're 18 inches
apart uh that some of the fruit very
high quality fruit they harvested all
the fruit for us and they sold it on the
farm
um don't know if it's going to be a
commercial shipping industry but it is a
nice local
um crop that will complement your
strawberry production
okay so the one of the the things that
Lisa always says can Pine bark do the
job is it going to work for us so we
know it costs eight to ten times less
this was video data and this is the
second potato data table that I'm
showing you today and not too
complicated
um coconut core versus pine bark
essentially the same yield so it was you
know it can do the job works just fine
and it's eight times less so it's um
it's like it's going to work out for us
um so is this another new crop for North
Carolina this is the Santa this is the
first year that we've ever actually said
yes we think it can be we're working on
the budget still to see if it works out
it might not work out for every grower
but it really has worked out for this
grower and we think there's a lot of
other larger Growers that are looking
for a raspberry crop to sell at the same
time these are strawberries and you get
through quality be consistent and may be
able to ship them as well
um and we know that pine bark works it's
a little bit trickier and we also know
that
all right so yeah so this is an adorable
we had uh early this spring
second round of uh trials and we had a
lot of interest there's a lot of Growers
there um
okay
okay I got four minutes left okay I'm
almost done here too okay so here just a
little plug with my raspberry Nantahala
um it was a wonderful raspberry it
tastes really good late primocane
sweetie not as high yielding as some of
the other ones out there
um only can be grown in our mountains
and other locations that are cooler
um large and in Heritage Courtney and
also Caroline yields lower than Caroline
um it's just you know a nice very not
you know it takes you know outstanding
it didn't really catch on North Carolina
but dog on it's that thing the the
Bernies people found out about it and
actually not who we wins but another
small company picked it up started
producing it started selling it to
birdies and they sell that thing for
16.99 a plant it is very popular in
Bernie's one of my friends and our old
colleagues Chad Finn said when he was a
little kid that's what he wanted he
wanted to have a variety available in
the nursery catalogs and he had you know
found out that if that was the only
thing he achieved in his career he would
be very happy so I'm very happy we got
and a Halo and they call it sweet repeat
Bernies but did you say it was romantic
um so lots of resources with the
academic extension mostly so there's
production guide diagnostic tools I had
a Blog that was really popular not able
to do it as much anymore but it was fun
to do it while I could
um we have a portal in North Carolina
too that means the extension website
basically for things we developed
instrument strategic plan so it's good
for our future grants and things
um we have printing videos we have prep
profiles budgets IPM guides and maybe
we'll have a long day diagnostic tool
and production guide in the future
so I think that's it lots of students
work with me thank them all
um Ian now I go to shout out to him he's
a new technician working for me he's a
recent Cornell grad here yeah so he's
down working with me and berries and
he's getting his hands in the
in the field a little bit more than we
had before I think it's funny the awards
um lots of Cooperators in my time thanks
a lot to Jim Bellingham who's really uh
set up the stage for all the wonderful
term plays of that I inherited because
he was a germatism aficionado so we have
some really interesting Plaza the bottom
slide here is the the long cane team
here
um Brian Jackson right here Ricardo
Hernandez Lisa the budget woman there at
Josh Mays there so you know we have a
nice team working on things lots of
Cooperators throughout time to both
private and public
um lots of funding agencies too
um and then last but not least I am also
as I mentioned director of the graduate
programs for a place to come we have
about 61 graduate students 24 PhD 23 Ms
14 MHS which is equivalent to your MPS
yeah so it's the terminal degree you pay
for it but it's really a popular degree
and it's really boost up our enrollment
I mean we have a lot of Faculty you know
I think 31 is a conservative they're
kind of bike nailed down who was
actually allowed to put to mental grad
history and spend something wrong on
there so we have everything from
landscape like this department there
this section does
um landscape designed to Gene editing
too so we had a wide range of options so
you know things that you could be
working in graduates but so come talk to
me I'm happy to talk to our best
suppliers and I'm talking to you about
things that you could do at NC State
it's warmer down there you don't have to
show the sound like there's no not in
the summer yeah
so it's a good place to live
and so any questions from anybody yeah
that was more appropriate or less
appropriate right
um and do you see any uh like oil oh
absolutely there's the way oh yeah so
Eastern is mostly Sandy the Piedmont we
have these clay types the mountains
they're Rocky type so yeah and it's
actually the soil profile of North
Carolina it's really beautiful I don't
know if you like show us but it's a way
different so yeah that's the whole big
Challenge and actually this these long
canes would you know alleviate all that
trying to figure out how to grow in the
soils and fertility so absolutely
that are
kind of reflective other zones too
how big are the containers of these long
uh genes come in like yeah I think
they're eight eight ounces eight inch
yeah and they come with substrate in
them from football they do yeah so the
shipping costs of those must be to
surprise it's not a cheap thing yes yeah
so that's what you know we're working on
that budget we'll see what that is but
then I you know I did mention too we're
trying to develop an industry or there's
a a nurseryman that works on other
things other crops up in the mountains
too so trying to develop a long hanging
industry there too so I would hope be a
whole lot less shipping if we're able to
do that as well yeah it's a very Dynamic
cortical changes through that last name
cooperate yourself
yeah uh we'll tell you different
questions in applied Horticulture kind
of like developing an industry
um over a long time now what do you what
do you see as some of the challenges and
opportunities for working as like
extension faculty in an applied setting
at North Carolina or just kind of at
large in the land grant University like
where where do you see like you know
some of the this heading for doing this
you know I think you got to continue to
reach out to the grower clientele you
know if I was a new faculty or a new new
faculty going anywhere just go around
and meet the new people and see what
they're going to do I didn't necessarily
do that because I knew we had methyl
bromide issues I knew that that was an
issue that needed to be tackled when
nobody was doing that in North Carolina
um so I knew that that's what I wanted
to do with strawberries and there's a
lot of fun thing out there
um and they were glad eventually that I
did that um for caneberries too that I
went around and talked to a lot of
Growers about that and you know asked
them if they would be interested in
growing libraries but just go around and
talk to the people my husband and I
actually when we first started North
Carolina just got on the road and
stopped at the research stations and I
had to grow our locations and said hey
we're here you know what do you know
what what's your problems
um and by far right now still is labor
issues so you know we can develop
cultural stuff we don't have
yeah is anybody online have a question
I don't see ya
hey thanks Gina yeah welcome thank you
this has been a production of Cornell
University on the web at cornell.edu